coelho também lançou o youtube é isso
que dentro de 40 acima de qualquer forma
[Música]
ainda não não é impossível
acompanhe por si um dique meu eu não
digo ok está tranquilo tranquilo
calma calma não vou tirar a máscara não
vou tirar a máscara não vou tirar a
máscara eu não vou tirar a calma eu vou
deixar que vai embora
boa ainda não estavam em frente estava o
fred também está a jogar muito bem
aconteceu alguma coisa kimmel alguém
está dentro da vila são josé dos campos
o palhaço a hora é agora eu já sei se
estou nos comentários
mas o que acontece é que com a opção do
jogo não conseguiu
como estava a dizer
são sim tamanha caraças são cinco da
manhã pessoal são cinco da manhã meu com
50 cursos que passaram a quinta noite só
se vocês não têm noção vocês não têm
noção que não conseguir falar ou pessoal
no cheque
vocês não tem noção de quanto tempo
fiquei a equipe só lancei o conseguir
calma calma para lá de chuveiro só
quando eu receber o cheque o pagamento
mas aí que conseguiu passar esta noite
fiquei muito bebê teria começado porque
tem muita coisa para aguentar a channel
1 20 euros tudo bem em 2011 com muita
coisa pessoal conseguir passar foi max é
fredes e agora tenho que cantar funk em
maio
[Música]